despite the popularity of Apple's iconic
designs the creative mind behind them
remains relatively unknown I'd like to
ask John e i of our senior vice
president of design to come up and take
us through that without Johnny Ive Apple
wouldn't be apple good morning he
created products that are not only
functional but emotional he made people
feel something when they held an iPhone
in their hand design was in his blood
his father was a silversmith and teacher
who helped craft a new design curriculum
for UK schools from which his son
benefited Mike Ive would constantly talk
to his son about design Leander caney's
book on Johnny Ive describes how when
they walk down the street Mike would
point out the different types of Street
lamps to his son and how their shape
affected how the light was cast design
offered him an outlet for his creativity
which is a common trait for people like
him who have dyslexia as his Christmas
gift his father would give him full
access to his Workshop where he could
build anything his heart desire desired
so long as he sketched it first Johnny
told Steve Jobs biographer Walter
Isaacson that I always understood the
beauty of things made by hand I came to
realize that what was really important
was the care that was put into it by the
age of 13 he knew he wanted to be a
designer but he didn't know what he
wanted to design when his work was
showcased at a design conference the
leading London design firm Roberts
Weaver group was so impressed that it
agreed to support him through University
if Johnny promised to join the company
upon graduation Johnny studied in the
north of England at Newcastle
Polytechnic now known as northumbria
University the Bauhaus design philosophy
that emerged in Germany in the early
20th century had made its way into
British design schools Bauhaus
emphasized minimalism including only
what is needed into designs objects had
clean lines simple forms and were
pleasing to the eye
that design philosophy heavily
influenced Johnny who brought the
Bauhaus aesthetic to Apple while at
University Johnny interned with a design
firm that was supporting him he had to
design a pen for a Japanese client and
he realized that people like to fiddle
around with their pens so he added a
ball and clip mechanism to the top of
the pen that served no purpose other
than to give someone something to do
this humanized the technology people
didn't want to just write with the pen
they wanted to touch it and play around
with it much like how they play with
their Apple products today Johnny worked
hard as an undergraduate student when a
friend visited his apartment he found
more than a hundred prototypes for a
landline telephone creating numerous
prototypes became his signature at Apple
even if the changes were small he felt
they were important to physically see to
know if they would be compelling to the
user although he designed Tech products
he didn't consider himself a tech guy
growing up the only computer that spoke
to him was Apple's Mac
it was a really profound moment you know
I don't think I've ever had actually
quite the same sense of wow you know
with with a product before he thought it
was a lot easier to use than any other
computer and he believed the designers
actually cared about the product and how
consumers felt when they used it he told
the design museum in London the more I
learned about this cheeky almost
rebellious company the more it appealed
to me the bursaries he received for his
Stellar work as a student gave him the
chance to travel to Silicon Valley where
he visited the studio of a star designer
Robert Bruner was impressed by Johnny's
phone concept unlike other student
projects it wasn't simply a mock-up but
included the internal components Bruner
asked him to consider joining his design
firm upon graduation but Johnny had
already promised to return to London to
work for Robert sweever Group which had
been financing his education a few
months later Bruner helped Apple
establish its own in-house Design Studio
up until then I Apple had contracted its
design workout to a German firm after
his big trip to America Johnny submitted
a report to the group that awarded him
the travel bursary writing I immediately
fell in love with San Francisco and
desperately hoped that I can return
there sometime in the future
back in the UK he spent a year and a
half with Robert's Weaver group before
he left to join the design startup
Tangerine co-founded by his friend a
former designer at Roberts Weaver at
Tangerine the four-person team designed
everything for clients from TVs to
toilets Johnny designed a minimalistic
comb for a Scottish hairdresser that
went on to win a prestigious prize but
sometimes he found it frustrating
working with clients who had a different
Vision than him for example a major
bathroom company was unhappy with
Johnny's toilet designs Raphael Leonardo
and Donatello they were named after the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the company
claimed they were too modern and too
expensive to produce the designs that he
put his heart and soul into were
literally flushed down the toilet
so when the California designer who had
been impressed by his telephone
prototype came knocking again Johnny
couldn't resist Bruner was the head of
industrial design at Apple John Scully
was the CEO of Apple at the time Steve
Jobs had been forced out of the company
he co-founded and was trying to make his
new software company NeXT succeed while
keeping his other company Pixar afloat
when Bruner hired Tangerine to work on
some potential future products for Apple
the team speculated it was just a ploy
to try to lure Johnny to California
California was a long way from London
Johnny also wasn't sure his wife would
want to move so far from home but there
were too many reasons to say yes Apple
would allow him to focus on his craft
rather than the business side of a
startup he could see a design through
from start to finish plus he had fallen
in love with a Mac so he packed his bags
for the Golden State Johnny's first big
assignment at Apple was the second
generation message pad a personal
digital assistant that laid the
foundation for the iPhone he designed it
to flip open from the top rather than
from the side because then it wasn't
culturally specific as people in North
America and Europe would want it to open
from left to right whereas people in
Japan for example might want it to open
from right to left he was always attuned
to the needs of the consumer he won
several awards for the message pad
though he really wasn't interested in
accolades he was humble and focused on
his work unfortunately Johnny Stellar
design wasn't enough the message pad
bombed due to battery issues and poor
handwriting recognition which The
Simpsons made fun of it was a lesson
learned and in the future Johnny made
sure he could influence the Engineering
Process as well Johnny quickly emerged
as Bruner's second in command Bruner
wanted his design team to come up with
Concepts that would excite people the
way they'd get excited over a new piece
of furniture at the time in the early
90s computers were becoming increase
increasingly popular in people's homes
but they were big and boxy Johnny
refined the design of the desktop Mac
into a slim flat screen computer the
first two units of the 20th anniversary
Mac were given to Apple's co-founders
Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak in 1997.
jobs was brought in as an advisor when
Apple bought his company NeXT but the
new Mac failed as well it was very
pricey at nine thousand dollars other
computers were selling for less than
half that price Bruner felt burnt out
and quit so Johnny Ive became the new
head of industrial design at just 29
years old but he had his frustrations
too he felt Apple's then CEO Gilbert
Emilio had no desire to innovate his
immediate boss promised him things would
soon be different Emilio was quickly
forced out as CEO and Steve Jobs was
back at the helm
it had been 12 years since jobs was
ousted from Apple when he returned he
held a meeting of top Executives Hive
recalls I remember very clearly Steve
announcing that our goal is not just to
make money but to make great products
jobs wanted Apple to focus on creating
first-class products that people would
be willing to pay a premium for much
like how people are willing to pay more
for a Mercedes over a Chevy jobs had a
vision of what he wanted Apple products
to be he told the New York Times most
people make the mistake of thinking
design is what it looks like people
think it's this veneer that the
designers are handed this box and told
make it look good that's not what we
think design is it's not just what it
looks like and feels like design is how
it works he entrusted Ive to execute his
vision of building beautiful and
functional products jobs told Isaac Sin
that Ive has more operational power than
anyone else at Apple except me the first
order of business was to create a new
desktop Apple had many products but no
standout product the company was close
to bankruptcy due to declining sales as
it faced competition from PCS with
Microsoft's new operating system Windows
Engineers had played a leading role in
the design process up until then they
determined the size of the device and
then the design team had to design an
enclosure that fit but when jobs
returned to CEO the design team started
calling more of the shots I've
constantly butted heads with John
Rubinstein Apple's head of engineering
who was actually his supervisor
Engineers weren't happy that they were
now forced to fit Hardware into a design
while thinking about the new computer a
member of the design team suggested it
should be translucent this was a
complete contrast to the dark gray look
of computers back then I've loved the
idea a lot of people at that point in
time were nervous around around
computers around technology
so so clear goal was you know how we
could make
um you know make the product accessible
not intimidating translucency made it
less intimidating I've also added a
handle to the computer this was not for
carrying but to build a bond with the
user to make it seem approachable he
explained to Isaac said if you're scared
of something then you won't touch it I
could see my mom being scared to touch
it so I thought if there's this handle
on it it makes a relationship possible
the importance of a personal connection
was reflected in the name of the
computer the i in iMac stood for
internet but it also stood for
individual
it was a make or break moment for Apple
when jobs unveiled the iMac in May 1998.
the whole thing is translucent you can
see into it it's so cool despite his
enthusiasm the reviews were mixed
journalists noted the lack of a floppy
Drive which jobs felt would date the
machine he wanted something that
represented the future a reporter with
the Boston Globe predicted that the iMac
will only sell to some of the true
believers how wrong he was people went
crazy for the iMac it went on sale for
12.99 and by the end of 1998 the iMac
became the fastest selling desktop in
history the iMac had a huge impact on
our culture suddenly it seemed like
everything in the late 90s and early
2000s was transparent the iMac was
constantly upgraded and also released in
multiple colors it set a precedent for
the iPod which was constantly improved
and released in colorful designs job saw
an opportunity to create a portable
music device that relied on the latest
digital technology rather than CDs he
wanted something small enough to fit in
your pocket and easy to use a wheel was
a clever way to navigate through the
menu interestingly there was no on off
button any button could turn the device
on and it turned off after a period of
inactivity which spoke to its ease of
use the iPod was beautiful besides the
stainless steel back that was easily
scratched
Johnny decided that the first iPod
should be white to emphasize the
Simplicity and elegance of the design
this was a breakthrough moment because
white would become the staple color in
Apple's lineup and is synonymous with
the Rand with Apple's success Johnny was
generously rewarded and was able to
enjoy himself in his downtime and
Splurge a little he had an Infinity for
British luxury cars which nearly killed
him while driving with another Apple
designer in the passenger seat I've lost
control of his Aston Martin and struck a
median the car was completely totaled
but thankfully both men survived and
there was still a lot to accomplish the
wheel on the iPod may have been a clever
way to navigate through the menu but
what about something even more intuitive
when the engineering team produced a
multi-touch system as a demo I've knew
it would be a game changer he decided to
show it to jobs privately because his
boss had a tendency to flat out reject
ideas and Ive didn't want him to reject
this one so quickly especially in front
of the entire team
in this case he had nothing to worry
about jobs agreed touch was the future
the idea of a touch device led to the
iPhone as with all Apple products the
iPhone was built in secret most of
Apple's employees were not allowed in
the Design Lab he showed jobs prototypes
of Top Secret Designs on wooden tables
outside his office which inspired the
big open tables at Apple Stores the
models were covered with a black cloth
when not in use
I've believed nothing should detract
from the iPhone screen he wanted it to
look like an infinity pool where the
displays seemed to extend endlessly with
no visible edges or boundaries
today apple is going to reinvent the
phone Apple released the iPhone in 2007.
hey Johnny how you doing
well it's been two and a half years and
I I can't tell you how thrilled I am to
make the first public phone call with
iPhone
the iPhone is widely regarded as one of
the most influential product designs of
the 21st century but there is one more
thing
why not make this screen bigger and turn
it into another product and we call it
the iPad
although the iPad came after the iPhone
job said the idea for a tablet came
first Apple once again established
itself as the standard Bearer for
Innovative products
by the time the iPad was released in
2010 jobs had already been diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer despite multiple
treatments and surgeries his health
deteriorated a year later in August 2011
he stepped down as CEO
when he was recovering from his first
bout of cancer jobs asked to see two
people his wife Laureen and Johnny Ive
as recounted in the book by leandercaney
jobs referred to Ive as his spiritual
partner they had worked together for
nearly 15 years and had lunch together
almost every day
one month after jobs resigned from Apple
he died on October 5th 2011. he was only
56 years old he famously said during a
Stanford commencement address that death
is very likely the single best invention
of life it is life's change agent it
clears out the old to make way for the
new Jobs family held a private funeral
that four Apple Executives attended
including new CEO Tim Cook formerly
Apple's Chief Operating Officer and
Johnny Ive
on the 10th anniversary of job's death
Johnny wrote a touching letter about his
friend which was published in the Wall
Street Journal
I think about Steve every day he said he
and Steve's Widow Laureen are close when
her brilliant and inquisitive children
ask me about their dad I just cannot
help myself I can talk happily for hours
describing the remarkable man I loved so
deeply I loved how he saw the world the
way he thought was profoundly beautiful
he truly believed that by making
something useful empowering and
beautiful we express our love for
Humanity
some wondered if Ive might return to the
UK after job's death
in 2012 he was knighted and became Sir
Johnny Ive but I've remained at Apple
for another decade and helped push for
the Apple watch in 2019 he left Apple to
start his own design firm love from
where Apple became his client he had
purportedly grown disillusioned with
apple undercook which had begun to focus
increasingly on selling software and
services rather than unsweeping design
changes
apple and Ives design firm parted ways
in 2022
Apple would not be apple without Johnny
Ive the question now is whether Apple
can continue to turn out beautifully
crafted Innovative technology without
his creative genius